il y aura des surprises
énormes dans un instant dans un instant
les Chéries il y aura une star
internationale qui va venir nous
rejoindre et c'est c'est personnellement
peut-être une de mes stars
préférés que je peux vous dire c'est euh
BAGAR et cheveux
euh vous dire c'est énorme c'est tout ce
que j'aime voilà donc je vous dis vous
frz parce que même les chroniqueurs ne
savent pas ce qui va se passer on
d'ailleurs des surprises pour vous dans
ce TPMP 90 ça continue après le
témoignage de malorinaf qui était très
très fort leschir on va revenir aussi
bien sûr sur des extraits juste je vais
demander aux deux personnes qui se sont
mises là les deux personnes de la la SCU
c'est derrière merci c'est juste voilà
parce
que a un
souci merci à tous hein vous êtes très
beau vous êtes très bien habillé merci à
tous d'être avec nous ce soir
franchement on va passer une très très
belle soirée on va revenir aussi sur des
extraits cultes des années 90 comme ce
fourir c'est un des fourir que je
préfère et c'était celui en 96 rappelez
de du gars Roger Zabelle oui sur TF1
c'était un journalist sportif et il
raconte une triste histoire d'un
footballeur à qui il est arrivé que des
tanases et regardez il part en F rire
franchement j'aurais eu le même on
dirait moi quand je parle d'une
péripétie au bois de
boulogneiste a donc un jour s'est servi
de son marteau picker il a touché un
câble à très haute tension 30000 V il
paraît que ça équivaut à peu près à 15
fois la chaise électrique et et ben il
s'est réveillé 14 jours plus tard et il
avait perdu deux doigts de pied il
avait c'est tout il y avait les tendons
du genou
brûlé une n plate explosé et puis alors
on lui a
greffé enfin on lui a agffé le mollet
droit sur Malet
gauche puis on lui a demandé on lui a
conseillé de faire un sport ass il a
choisi le
kayak on va parler de football après les
mésaventures de ce kayaquiste américain
que pour les
chéri on va rir sur plein d'image
d'années 90 et puis il y a ce téléphone
secret qui peut sonner à tout moment et
ça ce sera des surprises pour l'un
d'entre nous ou d'entre vous parce que
je suis pas au courant de toutes les
surprises il peut y en avoir également
pour moi et puis regardez il y a une
Game Boy géante qui a été faite par la
production bravo CAC et et derrière
derrière il y aura des surprises des
gens qui vont venir star international
dans un instant déjà dans les années 90
benim toi tu étais tu étais sur TF1 déjà
ou pas oui bien sûr fort ah ouais tu
étais déjà tu étais déjà une star toi
ouais non je démarrais vraiment je
prenais plus d'oseill que maintenant
franchement non mais c'est vrai c'est
c'est c'est sûr ou c'est sûr est-ce que
tu te rappelle c'était la les tartes à
la crème une des plus mythiques c'est
celle prise par le journaliste Alain
béverini au 93 bien sûr à côté de
l'ctrice Hunter Ctait qui Hunter en fait
c'est une grande comédienne américaine
le son de piano bien sûr le son de piano
ou il me semble elle avait joué dedans
ben sur regardez les teés sont
incroyables regardez les sourde muette
est-ce que ça a été difficile pour vous
d'interpréter justement le rôle
d'une bon écoutez je pense qu'il y a un
petit problème là décidément c'est pas
oui je crois qu'on pourrait avoir le
regard surtout de Holly Hunter hly hly
hly Hunter vous avez pu entendre
notre Holly Hunter pendant que Alain
béini ESS de se débarbouillé est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire s'il a été
difficile pour vous de disons s'adapter
à cette situation du GS la té du gars
est folle j'adore la té du
gars la té du gars elle est
incroyableement ce gars ce gars il avait
une teé à prendre des tartes à la crème
S c'est mal teé fol il est le gars il
est au bout de sa vie commentaire il est
au bout de sa vie on va continuer avec
on va voir un des plus gros malaises à
la télé c'était dans le 12 1 sur France
3 en 97 Catherine matoche pense recevoir
un invité et apparemment ils avaient la
même prote que nous parce qu'en fait ils
se sont plantés ils ont mis un gars qui
était pas le bon gars regardez c'est un
petit peu le du invité du 12 Antoine
godino exinpecteur pardon de la brigade
financière du SRP de Marseille merci
d'être d'être avec nous je ne suis pas
Antoine godino ah pardon excusez-moi euh
vous avez participé indirectement à à
cette enquête puisque des attendez il y
a une erreur de personne que se
passe-t-il nous avons un problème nous
avons un problème peut-on m'expliquer en
régie ce qu'est ce
problème vous nous
parlez nous avons un nous revenons nous
revenons dans un instant à vous
excusez-moi
incroyable on aurait pu avoir le
même on va revenir on va revenir
maintenant sur une image des années 90
j'espère passe un bon moment avec il
22h5 on est en direct on est là pour
encore longtemps il y a encore beaucoup
beaucoup de surprises notamment pour
vous autour de ce plateau et on va
revenir sur un des plus grands fourir de
l'histoire des JT la rivière
prout ça
toujours Moldavie ancienne république
soviétique des inondations d'une extrême
important ont fait au moins 50 morts
dans le centre du pays pendant 2 jours
des pluies torrentielles se sont abatttu
près de la capitale chicino et le niveau
de la rivière La proute s'est élevé de 5
m en quelques
heur à l'approche de l'Opel américain il
l'année dernière
finalisterouve for mais il s'est il
s'est qualifié pour la finale du tournoi
de Long Island dans la BL de New
York c'est
incroyable les Chéries on continue avec
une autre image c'est c'est une de mes
une des mes images préférées je crois
que c'est l'image où j'ai pas tapé la
plus grosse barre est-ce que vous
rappelez de l'émission mystère sur TF1
j'ai revu ça ça tourne beaucoup ça aussi
sur Youtube et c'est vrai que c'était
sensé être des trucs paranormaux sauf
que c toujours des trucs éclatés au sol
et il y avait un bail c'est qu'en 94 il
y a un motard il y a un motard qui est
venu il a dit ouais j'ai des super
pouvoirs il arrive sur le to plat il
arrive sur le to plat il avait fait une
vidéo où il a les yeux bandés où on le
voit faire des trucs de ouf donc
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont dit il on dit on va
le tester au plateau frère et
doncardve dit j'ai des super pouvoirs je
peux voir je peux conduire je peux
piloter ma moto avec un bail avec un
masque sans rien voir frère je t'expque
l'expérience elle a duré 15
secondes 14h25 Jean-Marie la forg arrive
au lieu de rendez-vous il ne semble
absolument pas nerveux son calme est
étonnant tout est prêt pour le départ et
sous nos yeux ébilles Jean-Marie
démarre premier croisement si Jean-Marie
continue tout droit il percute la
camionnette rouge à gauche incroyable il
l'a évité nous avons invité trois
experts illusionnistes j'emploie donc
maintenant pour reculter ses yeux des
balles de cach mousse des cotons de
façon à ce qu'il ne puisse pas voir je
lui souhaite beaucoup de succès mais
j'en doute
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
beaucoupire suis toujours posé pourquoi
le gars avant de pr la il veut pas dire
bon les gars on Arte on arrête tout
céit les me mais gars
ilutme le gars ilit que to il que c'est
Impe mais le gars il veut la quand
[Musique]
Mme extraordinaire c'est
extraordinaire ça c'est une
énorme franchement bravo aux équipes
parce envie qu'on REM un autre extrait
de le mystère des pommes volantes
rappelez pas personne avait dit dans
cette émission qu' s'était fait attaquer
par des pommes
volantes vra et la reconstitution est
incroyable et vous voyez vraiment des
pommes volantes c'est incroyable ai mais
ça ça je suis de Doig de Me
REM
inroable du grenier et qui pass à
travers la porte ça fais un trou
noirour dans la salle
[Musique]
côté
c'est très traumatisant al nous notre
problème c'était surtout de ne pas en
parler parce que dit les gens vont dire
ils sont
fousoupoup c'est extraordinaire les gars
ça c'est ça c'est c'est vraiment une CAD
je crois qu'on a une surprise les chéis
mais moi je repense quand même au gars
avec la moto pourquoi il a pas
dit pourquoi il dit pas stop c'est
un on on va on va regarder la meilleure
reconstitution du siècle c'était en 93
il y avait une émission qui s'appelait
les marches de la gloire ça aussi ça
tourne beaucoup sur Youtube qui parlait
des héros du quotidien et ce soir on va
revenir sur la tragique histoire de
guigit le cochon d'inde ah oui ah ou oui
qui a frôé la mort c'est une des plus
grosses cadares de la décennie
regarde 95 ce guigit prenait possession
de son territoire favori la cuisine ce
n'est pas encore l'heure du
dîner et pourtant git pr d'une fin
subite a décidé de dévorer la prise de
courant du réfrigérateur alors ce qui
devait arriver
arriva Monique Castell est désemparée gu
la joie de toute la famille est là en
vie oui oui ouiit oh qu'est-ce que je
vais
faireit je me suis dit faut faut lui
faire du bouche à
bouche non gigit ne peut pas disparaître
en tout cas monique a décidé de ne pas
baisser les bras Monique ne pense qu'à
ça alors elle redouble d'effort lorsque
l'extraordinaire semble se produire
c'est comme un compte de fit blotti dans
les bras de Monique guigit reprend ses
esprits et les enfants vont comme chaque
soir retrouver le 5è membre de la
famille
extraordinaire